[Music]
this is LKC a-15 it's a star 450 light
years away similar in mass to our Sun a
protoplanetary disk of dust and gas
surrounds it and in it new planets are
being born
when planets are first forming there's a
disk of material around the star when
it's very young and the planets
basically formed from all this debris
stuff hits and sticks together and it
grows bigger and bigger and bigger and
then it's gravity draws material in
[Music]
planta formation is like a demolition
derby there are a lot of similarities in
a derby the cars are racing around a
track going around in circles at
different speeds well it's the same
thing with planets the material is
orbiting the Sun it's going around and
they're all going at different speeds at
different angles different trajectories
sometimes this material collides and you
get a bigger object left over and that's
how planets grow it's how they form
from afar it looks beautiful but venture
up close and you'll be trapped in a
vortex of speeding material the material
the dust the grains of sand even the
bigger rocks are moving at orbital
speeds around this protostar so we're
talking about 10 15 20 miles per second
you might think that the large rocks are
the most dangerous but in space that's
not necessarily the case the bigger
rocks can be seen can be tracked things
this big can be tracked in space but
anything that's about this big is hard
to find in space you don't know it's
coming so while we're all fearing the
big rock if you're out in space you
better watch out for the small rock
that's moving fast if a pebble the size
of a BB pellet traveling at 40,000 miles
an hour hits Chuck our crash test dummy
it's going to cut right through
you know there are rules in baseball
that a batter has to wear a helmet
because there's a baseball moving at him
at a hundred miles an hour and if that
hits him in the head it could kill him
now imagine that that baseball is being
thrown a thousand times faster right
that would put a hole right through a
batter's head it wouldn't even slow down
that's how dangerous these things are
you